just to give a little backstory to my
situation
i probably
read ran past every red flag out there
early on
in my relationship
when i was in high school i was severely
overweight and
didn't have any luck with girls and then
started to work in the professional
world lost weight doing a job
and then met a single mom got hooked up
with her
um got married to her
we've been married for the last four
years and
uh how many kids did she have when you
met her
just one did you guys have any together
no
no and we were trying the entire time
and well before we even got married
but
unfortunately just nothing happening um
i actually went and got tested
and i'm i'm fine so
maybe it's a blessing in disguise
but
after right after we got married um
she
just fell into like this deep depression
or at least she claims that and she
became an alcoholic and
like to the point where she was storing
uh
liquor bottles in her car
i didn't even know this um and then she
threw herself into a rehab
i kind of thought it was a cry for
attention
um but when she came out she was just
she was just this completely changed
woman um you know just very demanding um
kind of very boss me around didn't like
me hanging out with friends
i was really starting to grow in my
career
i'm a building engineer
and
but she just the love has died and then
she just
basically says i'm unhappy i'm gonna
we're gonna file for divorce
and but right now we're both financially
broken because
she threw all of our finances
into the drain that was kind of wow
um
[Music]
honestly i don't know
uh clothes makeup
things for the house for the kid
for the dogs did she work or was she not
working yeah she works she's she's
full-time she works in the medical field
so she spent her money and your money
and you have nothing to show for it
except for some handbags and some makeup
exactly okay so what's the ask here so
you're getting divorced uh getting
divorced uh divorce gets finalized in
about two months
and
basically i'm just you know i've lost a
bunch of weight in the last two years
kind of drop dropped my weight by about
50 pounds i've been able to maintain 195
for the last two years
but
other than that i just you know i'm not
really sure where to go you know what to
do exactly what
with all this information i mean there's
endless information out there on the
internet it's easy to get lost in it
but just
um 32
okay and what does your life look like
in three years if you could paint a
picture
uh three years
i
hope to be in a manager position at my
job right now i'm a middle manager
would hope to be looking at possibly
buying some property
making some bigger investments um and
then really just
being in shape i don't want to
don't you're asking about the stuff that
you were consuming on the internet so
what sort of stuff are you consuming
that you're questioning
um
i mean i don't really question a lot of
it i i think i can i consume smartly i
don't i don't over indulge you know i'm
not looking at any of the red pill
content creators like a messiah you know
like everybody's going to have an answer
to this
i understand every man's journey is
different
but
it's it's hard to be
in this mindset you know and and be able
to see the flaws in the system
and really not be able to do too much
about it
you know i mean one of the things you
asked so i just want to back up because
one of the things that you asked you
said something along the lines of you
know i want to know where to spend my
time you know consuming content or what
content not to consume so i just wanted
to go back to that so
where did that come from like what are
you watching like what are you consuming
um for the most part um i will watch
youtube but i do a lot of educational
stuff like i'll watch a lot of content
that pertains to my work in electrical
engineering i watch a little bit of the
red pill content creators watch the
mechanics you know doing some
restoration stuff
but other than that
most of my time is spent at work or
doing projects around the house i do a
lot of work on cars in my free time
okay but what about like the stuff with
women in your life because i mean you
made a bad bad choice once right
yeah i definitely did um
you know i right now there's no there's
no real emphasis on spending time with
women because i still live with
my current wife
until the divorce is finalized
uh she's the same age as me she's gonna
be on the hook for support for her kid
uh no
no she's not she's not going after me
for that thank god you're lucky there
yeah um
dude just just uh just untie the knot
you know get your head screwed on
properly right
and just don't expose yourself to
problem women in the future
um
i mean
a woman that's gonna be
i mean like you said she turned in an
alcoholic and went all depressed right
yeah
okay
i mean
if
if you're a good dude you're a solid
dude she's in your frame
why would she get depressed
like why would she turn alcohol like why
would she do things like that right
right
no honestly back back then in the
relationship
you know i i kind of i found red i found
rolo's blog um about two months before
my wedding
um
didn't didn't find anything on youtube
didn't even know of
you know any of you guys making content
on youtube
and just read through
like for all the best of years
like well like all the way up until like
basically my like the day of my wedding
um
[Music]
and i tried not to let it leave a sour
taste in my mouth because i saw
i saw myself in a lot of these articles
and like basically how i was
setting myself up for failure
right
yeah right before saying i do
um
and i i had you know i had i had the gut
i had the worst gut feeling you know
when it happened you saw the building it
had slaughterhouse written on the front
of it yeah all right and then it had
like an entrance
that said hey just an enter here
like you knew exactly what you were
walking into but you walked into it
anyway right so now you've you know paid
the price with some time and some money
and some you know some sanity you
probably
have a little bit of bitterness you know
through the whole thing cool a little
bit now it's time to be better right now
it's time to
you know
now that you can cut that anchor loose
you know run the sails up
let them fill with wind and then move on
to your next passage
and you know sail on to
you know fairer waters right like you're
in a swamp right with this one you're in
a nasty ass moldy swamp right
yeah it's been it's been murky the last
couple of years yeah so just get your
ass out of there and you know sail on to
the caribbean where it's like kool-aid
colored water and things are better and
women are hot and pretty and
you know they're they're
they're nice to be around right yeah so
don't rush into doing anything stupid
like you did before like that should be
the biggest lesson here is
you know a lot of guys will say
something you know along the lines of
how can rich cooper give you advice on
women he's divorced blah blah blah
the very reason
that i'm able to experience the
knowledge that i have is because i've
made stupid mistakes in my life
right i've i've made a number of them
right so
you just have to like you know take it
on the chin there's a silver lining move
past it and just become a better version
of yourself see what i'm saying yeah i
appreciate it all right
all right thank you take care
you